I can't be a queen of auradon this isn't
goodbye dub Cameron but we're going to
miss seeing us mouth we really feel like
we've gotten to know you and the rest of
the BK's but then we realize we might
not know you as well as we know your
characters you may not be the queen of
worid on in the isle but we hope you and
your co-star boyfriend's have a happily
ever after
descendants three was epic but how much
do we really know about the stars keep
watching to find out all about the cast
real ages and relationships makes our
movie night seem a little tame
Sofia Carson when we first met Evie
she was totally boy crazy for Prince's
but then she fell in love with Doug the
son of dopey in real life Sofia has no
time for dating she says she's in a
relationship with her career she also
says that she doesn't want to date
anyone in the acting industry because
it's too much pressure if that seems
super mature it's because Sofia is
actually 26 years old she loved acting
in descendants but she is ready to move
on from playing a teenager Chyna and
McLean we're seriously going to miss
Emma we knew she was good all along she
just wanted what was best for the Isle
of the Lost but what about china anne
mcclain she is such a talented actress
and singer she is super busy right now
she's got an upcoming Netflix project
with Adam Sandler so she doesn't really
have time for dating she has that in
common with Yuma Chyna has a great
future ahead of her and she's still
super young she's only 20 Mitchell hope
all hail King then he's already turning
out to be a much better King than his
father the Beast this is the first
really big role that Mitchell has had he
does have a Christmas movie in the worst
but he still has time to date Mitchell
is dating Tyler Audrey another actor
they've been dating for a while they
even have a dog together Mitchell is 25
years old we can't wait to see what he
gets up to next
Dylan Playfair descendants three really
made us love gilt the son of Gaston he
proved that he was more than Emma's
Busey
we've totally loved the bromance between
him and J skill is played by Dylan
Playfair Gil isn't interested in dating
and neither is Dylan he's married to
another actor named Jenna rocky these
two got married in September of 2018
they're so cute together Dylan turned 27
years old in June 2019 we hope to see a
lot more of him in the future
boo-boo Stuart J the son of Jafar made
friends with Gil and is off traveling
the world but what about booboo Stewart
booboo had been dating Meghan Trainor no
not that Meghan Trainor Megan was a
chorus dancer on the first two
descendants movies and Jan Megan tend to
keep a low profile on social media boo
boo also used to have an Instagram
account with the Serena Evans called
at Peaks and Pines but there hasn't been
a post in over a year
boo boo is 25 and has a whole career
ahead of him
Brenna D amico who doesn't love the
daughter of the fairy godmother Jane
turned out to be a really smart strong
character we loved her avoiding the
sleeping spell in the new movie there
used to be rumors that Brenna D'Amico
was dating Cameron Boyce for a couple of
years but they never confirmed it
currently Brenna is dating Christian
Weisman he's also an actor Brenna is 18
years old and living her best life
Thomas Doherty everyone's favorite crazy
pirate is such a flirt it seems like
Harry hook was interested in every girl
in descendant 3 but there was a
suggestion that he ends up with Audrey
in real life Thomas Doherty is not the
Casanova that his character is he has
been happily dating dove Cameron for
years they met on the set of descendants
- Thomas is 24 years old he's got a
couple of TV series coming out in 2020
Sarah Jeffery Audrey played an amazing
villain in descendant 3 but we're glad
she learned her lesson and turned good
and she might even be dating Harry hook
but Sarah Jeffery has a very different
life she posts a lot of photos with her
charmed co-star Nick Hargrove they
haven't confirmed their relationship but
they look really close we just want to
know if they're actually dating Sarah is
23 years old
shy
in Jackson everyone is totally obsessed
with Hades the newest villain on the
block is cool and really cares about his
daughter mal I'm sure you to be very
happy together
Shia and Jackson is a famous Broadway
star but he has also acted in shows like
30 rock and Glee
he's been happily married to his husband
Jason Landau since 2014 the two have two
kids together before Jason Cheyenne was
married to Monty Lepke for two years
Cheyenne is 44 years old dove Cameron
mal is going to be the queen of auradon
and the Isle of the Lost and she is
perfect for it we loved how much her
character has grown over the three
movies as we mentioned before dove has
been dating Thomas Doherty for about
three years she has expressed her desire
to get married to him they're just so
cute together
we seriously can't get enough of this
real-life descendants love story there
has been some speculation that they got
engaged in Jamaica earlier in 2019 sub
is 23 years old we can't wait to see
what she does now that she's putting the
VK life behind her who is your favorite
star from descendants let us know in the
comments thanks for watching
don't forget to Like and subscribe for
more great content we'll catch you later
[Music]